[Musique]
par les enfants au froid j'espère que
mes petits amis on ramassait beaucoup de
champignons aujourd'hui dans les bois
[Musique]
alors je n'en mangerai pas trop je vous
le promets
ou
moins le fun
[Musique]
mais du coup la crise qu à les pendre
dans les lits viennent on est ainsi
gougaud clos fonds mange tout chaud elle
était toute blanche qu'elle est pour
demain la grange pour des petits
enfants mangent tous
les territoires qu à les pendre dans la
moindre est on est ainsi qu aux colons
font manger tout chaud l'été tout le
bruit qu'elle épandre dans la ginette
bontin tiko pour l'enfant qui peut
donnons
ce qu'est les choses cette chanson
ouais c'est ça naît ça ne m'étonne pas
vous avez fait une grande promenade
aujourd'hui on a ramassé beaucoup de
champignons par michou par michaud dans
les champignons à nous oui
tiens casey pour toi tu pourrais le
faire une omelette au oui une omelette
aux champignons
merci le second
un cornichon tu es toujours pieds lui
plaisait pas retrouvé mes souliers nous
je crois qu'il faut que je me force
à ne jouer de la guitare vient nous
[Musique]
vient du
jeu car mission oui
voilà
[Musique]
salut
ou
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nous nous
[Musique]
retournons vite à la baie sont pas trop
nous allons faire une bonne petite
enveloppe au shopping oh oh oh oui tu la
mangera demain car ce soir tu tombe de
sommeil
allons en route bonnut les enfants allez
vite vous couchez vous aussi aux autres
eut fait pour vous
[Musique]